hallo mein name ist luca und ich und
im oder gar nicht mehr gesehen wird wir
zeigen euch lied in minecraft wir zeigen
dass das jetzt machen und damit fangen
wir jetzt an
ja wir haben uns hingegen tollen ziel
rausgesucht des thi diesmal wir haben
jetzt martin zieht gar nicht gefragt
die letzte folge verlinkt ich euch mal
hier da waren 58 diamanten spawnen rum
da habe ich zwar nicht den sieg gezeigt
aber statt in der beschreibung jetzt
zeige ich euch allerdings bei hier den
zieht und zwar ist es gibt - 9 69 53 53
36 klinischen auswendig häufig machen
wenn ihr auch so klug sein die es geht
sagt dann lass doch mal einen like damit
ich habe einen traum wir setzen uns auf
den baum
also wir haben ja auf jeden fall ganz
klein zieht der einfach eine geile
landschaft hat und damit keine
koordinaten vorbereitet oder so sondern
wir wollten einfach mal zusammen mit
euch erkunden
du gehst hat nicht wirklich mit q
fleisch von der kuh hin oder kannst du
dem ziel aus mendig gesagt komm ich zeig
euch jetzt mal weg ist er jetzt mal
diesen übelsten zieht also wir sind
quasi hier vorne gerade des pont davon
an dem baum auch jetzt kommt der wieder
man ja wer aber auf jeden fall hier im
ziel dem wir euch jetzt nach zehn
minuten auch mal vorstellen
sie zeigen scheiße in der luft lässt
chapman hat nicht das dreirad mit drei
wörtern ich sterbe sterbe also wir sind
angespannt jetzt erstmals übelste
kreationen die schöne balladen alter
jetzt ein lover lover und war voll gut
wir zeigen euch nun den ziel also hier
sind übelste landschaft nach vorne sind
weges pont hier oben haben wir erst mal
so einen riesigen berg ihr könnt mal
wieder so ne geile sache macht mit ihm
zum glasboden oder so stellte ja genau
oder sommer hier in der ecke so dass
akdag und wieso einen glasboden drei
stück ich guck mal hier ein loch wo man
bericht kann
hier ist einfach überall so ein riesiges
loch schnell mal vor wir haben hier oben
gerade gesagt dass man oben sondern so
ein glas tee einpacken kann hier
manchmal einfach und reim machen ja hier
muss man glasboden rheinpark katharina
station ist so riesiger wasserfall mal
wieder da ganz oben hatten wir
ich dachte dass mein game chat also dass
sie nur zu mir telepathie warte ich
mache so romantisch
es geht nicht ich kann den command für
nacht
nein lass doch einzieht vorstellen
euro was ich gerade am horizont entdecke
das was wir gerade erst an zu regnen
da hinten war die romantische ecke mit
der fackel und hier vorne ist direkt ein
und touch it das machen was ihnen abgeht
ich war noch nie im unterwasser
templeton meine nase zu halten
aber ich hab bei der begriff niemals
jetzt überlebt und ich bin dumm ich bin
dumm hat dafür gerade gestorben drei mal
aber hier und nirgendwo ein bossgegner
ja egal
wir haben mein alter das ist gerade für
auch richtig
die zwei schnellsten weg macht oder
ausbau oder ein blog wie man auch im
etat hat ihren sitz genau das ist er
natürlich jetzt du hast hier 2 stellt
sie dann kann man vielleicht hier
irgendwie noch eine hin machen und dann
hätte man hier als ein geiles plateau
dann wird man ihn eine treppe gebaut
dann könnte man hier lagen hier dann
wohl am boden man kann so viel rausholen
ja und dann schauen wir jetzt mal weiter
was wir hier vorne noch so haben denn es
wurde bei dem sid gesagt dass wirklich
tatsächlich nur geile landschaft hier
sein sollen und hier auf der anderen
seite vom berg ist es tatsächlich auf da
ganz schön nach vorne schauen dürfe
nicht ins becken sprechen tut es sehr
leid aber
skelette sind hier leider nicht erlaubt
gehabt sie beobachtet sie habe nicht
geduscht bevor sie ins wasser gegangen
sind was du fühlst die musik aber wir
wollen nicht nein nein
juli spielt mit seinem leben nein peter
g hewitt kann doch maximal noch ein herz
hatte wird jetzt wirklich ernst ist
wirklich ernst reuter wir haben gerade
eine kleine schutzfunktion für den kita
gebaut
so kann jetzt definitiv nicht mehr
verbrennt liter das ist alles nur zu
deinen besten müssen jetzt vorstelle wir
machen nur scheiße
die komplette serien einsatz
wir lassen jetzt peter da vorne erst mal
einen echten übelsten wasserfall gebaut
nicht dass er bei dem zieht jetzt
vorschule und so denkt wow war dem sid
dass in wilster wasserfall ein skelett
mitbürgerin ja jedenfalls wenn man hier
vorne rum schwimmt diekmann alter hier
sind einfach seinen gewässern seemitte
ist auf jeden fall so ein teich mit
einem im wasser hier vorne ist auch
wieder so ein kleiner fluss und hier ist
halt auch sonst übels alter dsl mega und
guck mal dass sie das freibad hier so
kinderbecken ein bisschen und dann wenn
man hier so lange läuft weg so richtig
die front der für die schwimmer
wir haben schon 20 mal gesagt aber mit
den zieht feuchte ja auf jeden fall ist
dass wir die andere seite vom berg hier
wo halt auch wieder das ist ich mache
also ich sag euch unten zieht hat den
platz in der syker nicht verdient so
lange keine ein blog scheiß ab
jedenfalls dass ihr dieser sieht von der
anderen seite wir können hierdurch noch
quasi durch fliegen dann sind wir wieder
hier bei dem titel das zitatrecht
ethisch aus die und es auch wieder so
ein kleines lava bäckchen da unten geht
es runter wieder in irgendeine
unterirdische höhle wieder ganz viele
mob sind das war jetzt auf jeden fall
die feature von heute vielleicht war sie
ein wenig verrückt
aber es war gut aussieht wurde aus der
ceo gerade die suizid show
es tut mir leid dass wir heute wirklich
nicht so viel vom sieg gezeigt haben
aber es weiß halt man etwas andere folge
wo wir uns gedacht haben ja es hat
einfach eine geile landschaft dann ein
kunde will durch die landschaft uns hin
zu behindern wie sonst auch wenn er das
ganze gefallen hat würden wir uns über
einen bewertungen freuen wenn ihr noch
einen zweiten part wollen oder einen
vierten oder fünften in die kommentare
was wären denn diese coole die gucken
schon die ganze zeit an nummer
aufgefallen ist hier sind drumrum halt
auch so mega inseln ja gut freundlich
werde er sie das video wenn ihr selbst
kanal mögt dann hast ihnen tschüss